in political debates it's easy to fall
into abstractions to think of Politics
as simply a matter of ideas floating in
The Ether rather than as real policies
that affect real people this is
especially true when we talk about
transiting the kids which is a very
popular topic of discussion on both
sides of the aisle the whole thing is so
bizarre most people have no idea what it
looks like in practice
this is what it looks like this is what
giving a 16 year old girl testosterone
looks like
so I got out of my haircut
um because my hair was driving me nuts
and I shaved it because I'm tired of
watching my hair thin out and it's less
distressing if I shave it so when I talk
about being too far gone not I don't
really know what else to call it
um this is what I mean this is how deep
my voice is
um it's gotten deeper over time and it's
settled
um this is what I mean by hair loss and
it just keeps getting worse it keeps
thinning it keeps receding backwards
um
you know and I'm not exactly sure that's
coming back
um those are the main things when I talk
about being androgenized
um to a point of no return
um I really don't see those being
fixable
so that's when I talk about you know
just kind of staying how I am regardless
of how I feel
um that's why just because I I don't
really see me personally being able to
come back from what's happened so far so
I hope that's a little explanatory
your heart just breaks for this girl
and it breaks Because deep down you know
that she's right
there is no way to undo the damage
inflicted on her body by the adults who
mutilated her body
I'm not saying that all hope is lost it
isn't I'm not saying that she can't live
a wonderful life she certainly can but
something really was taken from her by
every adult who should have known better
and who allowed this to happen from her
immediate family all the way up to
President Biden who pushes this stuff at
the federal level okay something was
really taken from her and we we labor
under this delusion in Modern Life that
nothing's permanent everything's
reversible there's no all of your
commitments all of your obligations all
of your decisions about your own body
and your life none of it's permanent you
can just change whatever but that's not
true that there is a lot of irreversible
damage that came as a result of this
transgender insanity this fad that's
going to pass but the damage is not
going to pass you'll notice the left
never promotes these videos
the left never shows you mutilated kids
or forget about transgenderism for a
second left never shows you dying babies
in the womb the left never shows you
crime in the Border towns that the left
never shows you addicts who overdose on
drugs the left never shows you any of
the actual effects of their policies
the left does the opposite the left
relies on euphemisms that's what
political correctness is vague words
intended to hide harsh realities
intended to deceive
that distinction tells you everything
you need to know about American politics
in 2022 in order for the Left To Win It
needs to hide the reality of what it is
doing in order for the right to win it
just needs to convince people to open
their eyes I'm Michael Knowles it's the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Heather Webb
who says Madonna is going through the
world's longest midlife crisis that's so
true the country is going through a
midlife crisis
the country is going through this
absolute what is a midlife crisis a
midlife crisis is a refusal to
acknowledge the reality of one's own age
and the passage of time and the passing
away of certain frivolities and the
taking on of new responsibilities and so
what what do we all want to do we want
to all pretend that we're kids again but
the sad thing about a midlife crisis is
it pretending to be a kid again is never
going to help it's only going to make
things worse and that's what we're all
going through we're as a country we're
refusing to get married we're refusing
to have kids we're refusing to take on
responsibilities we're refusing to do
adulting you know to grow up we're in
just in Never Never Land and it's it's
great when little kids act like kids
good for them but when adults act like
kids things go really really wrong time
is passing you are getting older and you
will I promise you die someday that's
why you need to check out epic will
right now head on over to epicwill.com
use promo code Knowles for those of you
who have been following the story
Vanderbilt Hospital has agreed to pause
all gender transition surgeries on
minors this is a big win a leftist
institution has caved to pressure from
the right that deserves some recognition
but the fight is far from over there is
so much more that we can do to protect
our children from Evil leftist
indoctrination one very simple thing
that you can do today is write a will
many new parents don't realize how
important it is to have a will in place
even I until very recently did not have
an updated will that took into account
my kids and all my stuff and the last
will I had was from when I was 18 or
something like that I just finally
signed on the dotted line and finished
my will because I took a little bit of
time to make all the decisions but you
can create a will right now it's very
very simple costs 119 bucks for a single
person when you use promo code Knowles
kwles you will save 10 percent go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s to save 10 on Epic Wheels
complete will package that's
epicworld.com promo code Knowles
some people are opening their eyes
and even people who were democrats for
their whole life even people who were
professionally Democrats even people who
ran for president in the Democrat
primary and then dropped out and
endorsed the Democrat nominee Joe Biden
even they are waking up and they are
leaving the Democrat Party
namely Tulsi gabbard
I can no longer remain in today's
Democratic party that's under the
complete control of an elitist cabal of
War mongers who were driven by cowardly
wokeness who divide Us by racializing
every issue and stoking anti-white
racism who actively worked to undermine
our god-given freedoms that are
enshrined in our constitution who are
hostile to people of faith and
spirituality who demonize the police but
protect criminals at the expense of
law-abiding Americans who believe in
open borders who weaponize the National
Security State to go after their
political opponents and above all who
were dragging us ever closer to nuclear
war
now I believe in a government that's of
the People by the people and for the
people
unfortunately today's Democratic party
does not instead it stands for a
government that is of by and for the
powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats to
join me in leaving the Democratic Party
if you can no longer stomach the
direction that the so-called woke
Democratic party ideologues are taking
our country
and I invite you to join me
she is 100
correct every word she said every
syllable she said is correct
there's no but there's no but I I often
do not focus on the stories of
so-and-so's leaving the left or the
liberals or the Democrats or whatever
because I just think okay yeah we always
cheer when some lib you know is no
longer comfortable in Democrat party and
we make a big to do out of it but
usually the person remains fairly
liberal
or vice versa you know some liberal
Republican finally says okay I hate
these conservatives I'm thinking of Adam
Kinsey or Liz Cheney or whatever but
some big lib who pretends to be a
republican says okay I'm not going to be
a republican anymore and all of a sudden
the libs cheer and they they go crazy
and they make a big to-do out of it I
think it's often disingenuous
but what we're seeing here from Tulsi
gabbard is something
genuinely novel
you don't get the impression
listening to that that she while she was
just mistaken to be a Democrat come on
Tulsi you know you're just see you're a
republican you just don't know it yet no
that's not you don't get that feeling
you get the feeling that she could have
fit into the Democratic party maybe at
some point but there were always things
that were a little different I think
Tulsi gabbard
genuinely isn't independent
the thing she's talking about there are
kind of edgy she's calling out
anti-white racism that's the sort of
thing that you really are not permitted
to call out in either party
certainly not until very very recently
you were not allowed to call that out
she's calling out warmongers in both
parties again this is the sort of thing
that you're you're not really allowed to
talk about right now the Democrats are
absolutely belligerent over the war in
Ukraine they're they're they seem
bloodthirsty for for a more direct
confrontation with Russia that's
certainly been the effect of what the
administration has done that's what
she's calling out she's totally right
and Republicans are kind of mixed on it
Republicans certainly during the bush
era and since then they've kind of just
gone along with the National Security
State
speaking of the National Security State
she's calling out that the government
spying on us
neither party really calls that out the
Republicans cheered it on
as especially during the bush era the
National Security state began to take
more and more power to spy on civilians
the Republicans were totally fine with
that and now the Democrats are the one
wielding that power the Democrats are
the ones who wield the IC and all of
those surveillance powers to spy on the
Trump campaign to undermine the
Republican nominee for president to
undermine his administration to go after
ordinary conservatives
to attack not just Trump you know and to
to knock down the door of Mar-A-Lago
practically
because because Donald Trump is the
chief political rival to Joe Biden but
to go after parents who say we don't
want our kids to be taught weird stuff
in schools to go after ordinary
conservatives who who are now maligned
as insurrectionists and terrorists and
far-right semi-fascists
so you can't really call it out an
either party Chelsea gabbard is actually
just kind of opening her eyes up to the
problem of the liberal blob the liberal
establishment
that is pushed by the left and that is
largely tolerated by the right so I
cheer her on I have no but here I
suspect she and I disagree on certain
issues that she did not bring up in that
video
but in that video in her Declaration of
why she's leaving the Democrat Party she
expresses a clearer view of political
reality than every Democrat and then
most Republicans incredible stuff I
cheer her on and frankly I think what
you're going to see and you're already
beginning to see this the Trump movement
I think was fairly representative of
this
you're going to see a kind of third
force in politics emerge
that that really sees
far greater similarity between the
establishment Republicans and the
Democrats than difference they're going
to say that the Republican Democrat game
that we've seen certainly for the last
20 30 years is is really just kind of
two sides of the same coin it's a kind
of sock puppet battle where whichever
party wins the problems that really
matter to Americans are going to get
worse whichever party wins immigration
is going to become more and more of a
problem whichever party wins the
hollowing out of American manufacturing
is going to get worse and worse
whichever party wins the foreign policy
is just going to be the same old swampy
stuff that's been conducted since the
end of the Cold War and they're going to
see this seems like kind of a rigged
game and you're going to see more
independent thinkers whether or not that
can coalesce into a cohesive political
movement that remains to be seen But
Tulsi gabbard has taken a huge step in
that direction and she looks good doing
it and if you want to look good you got
to check out missing in Maine right now
head on over to mizzen and maine.com use
promo code at Knowles I am very
particular about my shirts I am for a
couple reasons one I have a very
particular sense of style and two I'm of
Italian extraction and so we tend to
sweat a little bit mizen in Maine has
the answer to both mizzen and Maine was
born when their founder saw a sweat
drenched DC staffer running into a
meeting wrinkled stained exhausted
disgusting okay his shirt needed a
refresh that is what drove visiting
Maine to make the world's first
performance fabric dress shirt ten years
later they now make incredibly
comfortable flannels no tuck shirts
performance polos those are some of my
absolute favorites that they make by the
way chinos so much more all in that same
performance fabric Thing I love about
these guys they get what you need from a
very practical level you know that the
the usefulness of the shirt to keep you
from sweating everywhere is really
really great but the style they
understand style understatement class if
you want the best dress shirts money can
buy check out mizzen in Maine right now
if you want to go to missing and
main.com and you use promo code Knowles
you will receive 35 off any regular
price order of 125 bucks or more that's
35 bucks off when you go to m i z z e n
a n d m a i n.com use promo code Knowles
people are leaving the Democrat Party
they're identifying less strongly with
the Democrat Party because the reality
of democrat policies is now undeniable
because we see it when we go to the gas
tank and we see it when we go to the
supermarket and we see it when we look
at the first major war in Europe since
World War II and we see it when we see
these poor little kids getting trans
okay you can't you can't deny that
anymore and so as a result the
Republicans are just much more popular
there's a survey just came out this is
from morning consult it's the political
intelligence poll it's just a ranking of
the popularity of Governors and you can
see here at the top here are the top 10
most popular governors in the country
one two three four five six seven eight
nine of them are Republicans nine of the
top ten most popular governors in the
country are Republicans heading into the
midterm elections looking forward to
2024 in the presidential election
really really bad sign for Democrats
so could them are Democrats guaranteed
to get completely blown out no and why
why not because the Democrats still
wield an insane amount of power the only
way that they're going to win is if they
rig the game I'm pretty confident to say
that I don't think that that is that
that is uh tinfoil hat or anything
barring some major change in World
politics right now if you look at all
the numbers today Biden's approval
ratings the generic Congressional ballot
you look at the specific races you look
at the most popular politicians in the
country there is no way that the
Democrats don't get blown out of the
water unless they cheat and they can
cheat in ways that are technically legal
too so I'm not saying that it's going to
be a cabal of shadowy alien reptiles who
are you know working with Hugo Chavez to
change voting machines it doesn't it
could be that I guess but I'm not saying
it has to be that what they can do is
similar strategies that they've tried
especially in 2020 and before that which
is that they can push for widespread
mail-in ballots
they can push pull Watchers out of out
of the room where they can take a long
time to count the votes so that there is
less oversight on Counting the vote
they can encourage non-citizens to vote
they can
they can
extend election day to election season
they can do all the stuff that they have
ordinarily done and we know that they
are doing some of that right now there's
a story
out of Colorado
voting is generally controlled by the
secretaries of State the state
secretaries of State the Colorado
Democrats Secretary of State uh
accidentally sent thirty thousand voter
registration notices to non-citizens
oops Whoopsie Daisy yes that's right 30
000 or so non-citizens living in
Colorado were mistakenly sent postcards
late last month encouraging them to
register to vote because uh Jenna
Griswold's office the Democrat Secretary
of State uh sent them out uh they
compared a list of names of a hundred
two thousand people provided by the
electronic registration information
center to a database of Colorado
residents issued driver's licenses
because of the difference in the lists
the non-residents the non-citizens
rather got
got the notices
maybe this was just a mistake
I'm a little skeptical of that a lot of
mistakes don't you think
it's amazing the election of Democrats
is the leading cause of mistakes and
coincidences and whoopsie daisies in the
whole country I'm a little skeptical
that it was a mistake but let's say that
it is that's no excuse
the fact of the matter is non-citizens
are being encouraged by democrats by the
state to go out and register to vote we
know that Democrats want non-citizens to
vote Democrats in in certain cities are
trying to make non-citizens eligible to
vote places like New York places like
San Francisco
we know that Democrats are trying to
make it easier for people who should not
vote vote we know that they're doing
this with convicts we know that they're
doing this with people when they go get
their driver's licenses this is we know
that the Democrats are flooding the
country with non-citizens to get an
electoral Advantage they've written
about this they've bragged about this
this is the strategy you're not allowed
to say it but because you'll complain
about it but they are allowed to say
because they're celebrating it and
they're pushing that strategy
that's what they're going to do why are
they doing that it's not because they
support democracy I'll tell you that
they supported democracy then they would
allow the people to run their own
government but they know their policies
are not popular and so they've got to
rig the game these politicians these
Democrats look really really bad there's
a Louisiana Democrat who's running for
congress who just released an ad focused
largely on defending abortion
in the ad there is video of her actually
giving birth to her son
I'm Katie darling and I live on a farm
in Saint Tammany Parish
our family compost collects rain water
and grows our own food
my husband and daughter helped take care
of the chickens
and there's someone else who's going to
be joining us and helping to pitch in
with Farm Life very soon
but these days I worry about storms that
are stronger and more frequent because
of climate change
about our kids underperforming Public
Schools and about Louisiana's new
abortion ban one of the strictest and
most severe in the country
we should be putting pregnant women at
ease now putting their lives at risk
I haven't spent my career in Washington
I've worked my way up from bartender to
CEO
now I help nurses organize our
complicated health records
because nurses aren't just Heroes
they're Saints
Louisiana deserves better than the path
we're on
I'm Katie darling and I'm running for
congress because I want that better path
for you for her and here we go
for him
that is the most psychotic ad not forget
even psychotic it's the most
Psychopathic political ad I have ever
seen in my in my entire life excuse me I
wasn't getting choked up I just hiccuped
but I could be getting choked up that is
absolutely
psycho
one if you if you run for office at all
you're you have at least a 15 chance of
being a psychopath just generally in
either party
then if you invite a political film crew
in to roll tape while you're giving
birth you have a 99.7 chance of being a
stone cold psychopath and then if you
can hold your newborn baby boy and look
into the camera
and
celebrate the right to dash his brains
out to that's actually not what happens
in an abortion if you would defend the
right to uh poison him and then
dismember him this little newborn baby
that you are holding in your hands that
the legal right to rip that baby limb
from limb not five seconds before that
ad could have been filmed
you have a one
100 chance of being a psychopath which
this woman obviously is and it got me
thinking why the hell would she ever air
this she looks nuts she looks like a
stone cold killer and I suspect the
thinking here was
to try to to try to split the baby on
the issue because Louisiana is a largely
pro-life state
she's running as a Democrat and so she
doesn't want to seem completely cold in
callous like the infanticidal maniac
that she is so she says okay what I'm
going to do is with my words I'm going
to defend abortion
and then in my actions I'm going to seem
like a loving mother and so I'm going to
appeal to both people the kind of
traditional voters and also the psychos
who want to kill all the babies and for
me at least probably for you
the effect of that is the opposite she
just looks like Lady Macbeth out damn
spot you know dashing her baby's brains
out
but I suspect that was a little bit of
the thinking there
the other really telling thing here is
everyone in in the
in the ad is seen every subject of the
ad is seen the husband gets a lot of
face time the little little daughter
gets a lot of Face Time the candidate
obviously gets a lot of Face Time
the only person who we see a little bit
of the of the person's back but we never
see the person's face is the newborn
baby
and now this I think ties right in with
what we were talking about at the top
it's very hard
to support abortion if you see a little
baby
and newborn babies are cute their faces
are all kind of smushy and cute you know
so you would think in a political ad if
you're if you're Stone Cold psycho
enough to push your birth in a political
ad you want the cutest part of the whole
scene in the ad right the most appealing
attractive part but she can put the
baby's face in the ad
for the same reason that the libs can't
show you the the actual transgendered
kids
who have had their bodies mutilated for
the same reason they can't show you the
actual border towns where all of those
illegal aliens show up for the same
reason
that they can't show you all of the
overdose victims of their drug policies
they can't show you the reality of the
policies that they are advocating
the libs used to
used to split the baby a little more
artfully on the issue of abortion this
is how you got the clintons
incoherent but somewhat politically
attractive scheme of safe legal and rare
abortion which appealed to centrists
even though it doesn't make sense
because if abortion is murder then it
shouldn't be legal and if abortion is is
morally neutral then it there's no
reason for it to be rare
but but now that the Democrats have
taken the much more aggressive sort of
sacramental view of abortion On Demand
with that apology up until the very
moment of birth and at least they're
being honest about their views in some
ways I appreciate that more than them
trying to pretend trying to have it both
ways on the issue of abortion but
they're making claims on abortion that
just don't make any sense at all one of
which is now the Democrats frame all of
their political issues as essential to
democracy democracy with a capital D and
everything the Republicans do it's not
just that it's bad it's not just that
it'll lead to a less flourishing Society
it's that it's a threat an existential
threat to our democracy and so now the
Democrats are claiming this was a
panelist on MSNBC claiming that
a legal abortion is essential to
democracy
and the backdrop to that candidacy is uh
women losing the right to an abortion
for the first time in 50 years
absolutely yeah I mean the rollback of
women's rights here is very concerning
and it is tied and I think look we many
of us understand how profound the
rollback you know of abortion rights
after Dodds is for women's autonomy and
ability to thrive in this nation what I
think we talk less about or think less
about is what that does to undermine
democracy that ultimately women's full
and equal participation in society at
every level including bodily autonomy is
fundamental to democracy functioning
what does that woman think democracy
means
democracy is government by the people
that's all democracy is democracy is
when people vote and the majority rules
that's democracy
in what world is abortion necessary for
democracy
what if most people
vote to Outlaw abortion
that would be an expression of democracy
most people are women by the way
when women are the only majority that
has ever somehow been presented as a
minority in public it's kind of strange
but
why
so you get and you're seeing this now in
a lot of red States
not just a slim majority of people but a
strong majority of people
through their elected representatives
Banning abortion or severely restricting
abortion
that would be an expression of democracy
just by definition but not according to
that woman why because
when the Liberals use the word democracy
they don't really mean democracy they
don't like democracy that's why when the
people elect Trump they say this is an
assault on democracy and of course it's
not it's an expression of democracy when
the people elect Georgia Maloney in
Italy it's an assault on Democracy even
though most people voted for it when or
at least the plurality of people and
most people voted for the Coalition when
when the majority of hungarians elect
Victor Orban who's a conservative they
say this is an assault on Democracy
because this woman
is saying not that abortion per se is a
prerequisite for democracy she's really
saying liberalism writ large
is essential to democracy now that's not
true it's not you can have you can have
a conservative democracy you can have a
communist democracy you can have a
liberal democracy you can have a fascist
democracy you can democracy is just what
the what the majority of people want
right that's all that is
so they specifically mean a liberal
democracy
a democracy where the people don't
really have a right to question the
central tenets of liberalism which
include
self-definition which include a maximal
autonomy which include in practice
killing babies and transiting the kids
and destroying the in the family and
tearing down Beauty and and and ruining
your Society
that's what it means and they're saying
that's that stuff's non-negotiable
in order to have the Democracy as we
envision it that stuff is completely
non-negotiable
the liberalism is what it's all about
and the liberalism is not supported by
the majority of people where that MSNBC
lady and where the left thinks that
liberalism and democracy are synonymous
sane people realize they're actually at
odds
because most people don't want all that
grip
so they're at odds and when they're at
odds the left is pushing liberalism
liberalism is a minority political
movement pushed by a small group of
elite yet very powerful people from the
top down on the rest of us and the rest
of us cut across all sorts of
demographics racial religious Geographic
even partisan these days that's what
you're seeing when Tulsi Edwards says
I'm leaving the Democrat Party it
doesn't represent me anymore she's
saying I can't
I know the Democrats theoretically are
in power but they're not representing me
they're not representing what most
people want
liberalism and democracy are at odds
whenever you hear people call America a
liberal democracy it's just completely
bogus even that term I gave a speech on
this not that long ago at the national
conservatism conference that term
liberal democracy is a very new term it
appears nowhere in the Constitution
nowhere in the Declaration of
Independence it nowhere in the
Federalist Papers
every time democracy democracy is not
mentioned in the first of those
documents at all every time it's
mentioned in the Federalist it's only
done so negatively liberalism is not
used to refer to a political philosophy
in any of those documents the term pops
up in the 1930s and then it starts to
gain a little bit of fraction in the 50s
it doesn't really explode until 1982. if
you just look at a simple Google engram
search of English literature it doesn't
doesn't really begin to take off until
the 80s so if America's a liberal
democracy that would be news to everyone
for the first 200 years of America's
existence it's just bogus it's just
totally bogus and you've got to pick a
side in this particular battle between
liberalism and democracy which side are
you on well that's the battle right now
between not the left and the right
exactly not between the Democrats and
the Republicans exactly it's between
what you would call the modern
liberal establishment
and the kind of trumpian Naga populists
that's that's where that fight is okay
and it's why you're seeing a kind of
weird shake-up of the political climate
where you've got even a Democrat
presidential candidate like Tulsi
gabbard she's now clearly moving to the
right she's at the very least leaving
the Democrat Party you're seeing
establishmentarian liberals like Liz
Cheney and Adam kinzinger move over to
the side of the kind of Democrats that's
what the never Trump movement was that's
you're you're seeing this this total
shake-up right now it's why Joe Biden is
excluding Trump supporters from his even
scheme of politics he's saying look I
have no problem with Republicans I just
have a problem with Maga Republicans
they're not mainstream what are you
talking about dude 90 plus what is it
probably 93 of the Republican Party
supports Donald Trump or has supported
Donald Trump at some point you're
talking about a tiny sliver I'm being as
generous as I can to the never Trump
movement and saying it's six or seven
percent of the Republican vote and Joe
Biden says no that's the legitimate
mainstream Republican view no it's not
Joe Biden is actually proving the point
of the populists Joe Biden is proving
the point of of the independence and of
Tulsi gabbard where he's saying listen I
support Republicans as long as they're
part of the uni party liberal
establishment that only gives you the
illusion of choice but doesn't actually
offer you any difference well no damn it
we we don't want any kind of uniparty or
any sort of sock puppet game we want a
choice not an echo to use the words of
Phyllis Schlafly in the early days of
the post work post-world War II
conservative movement that's what we
want that's what Tulsi gabbard wants
that's what Donald Trump wants
that's what people called the new right
one
that's what the people who are
disillusioned with this is what
Republicans other than the Liz Cheney's
and the Adam kinzingers of the world
want okay
which side are you on in that battle you
can't you can't just go back to the
1980s there are some very nice amiable
Republicans who just wish we could go
but take a time machine and go back to
the 1980s wasn't that so great I love
Ronald Reagan yeah I like Reagan too I
don't like the the caricature that some
squishes have made of Ronald Reagan
Ronald Reagan was a tough dude okay
Ronald Reagan got the same kinds of
attacks that Donald Trump got they
called him a Nazi and a racist and
outside the mainstream and Fringe and a
cowboy and all that stuff okay and I
think a lot of the people who extol the
virtues of Reagan today they would have
been bushies back in the 80s they would
have been on the establishment side it's
just my hunch okay
but we're in a different age now the
battles that were going on 40 years ago
are not the battles that are going on
today and Nostalgia is history after a
few drinks and we are we are I think
obligated to exercise some political
courage and say no we're in the battles
right now and it's not enough to bury
your head in the sand
and go along with uh the kind of
established view that the Disney the
Disney World version of politics no
because Disney is trancing the kids too
no you've got to pick a side which side
are you on
you know back in June of 2020 Candace
Owens
took to social media to question the
narrative about George Floyd
she took a barrage of insults as a
result celebrities insulted her GoFundMe
de-platformed her as the attacks ramped
up daily wire plus gave her a platform
to speak out without fear of being
silenced and supported her investigation
into black lives matter that
organization raised 80 million dollars
or more through fundraising but no one
ever asked where the money went until
now tonight Candace Owens will reveal
the truth in her new documentary the
greatest lie ever sold exclusively on
daily wire Plus
more than two years later the story you
never knew is more relevant than ever
and finally the truth is coming out the
longer the media stays silent the louder
we get the more momentum we gain your
daily wire Plus Membership goes a long
way to ensuring folks like Candace Owens
and Matt Walsh and everyone here has a
megaphone free speech is our greatest
weapon remember we are speaking for you
and fighting for your beliefs as well if
you are not yet a member go to
dailywire.com to subscribe and join us
today tune in this week to watch Candace
owens's new documentary the greatest lie
ever sold exclusively on daily wire Plus
I found my favorite Washington Post
article this week
every week I think they've reached the
absolute bottom of the barrel I mean the
Washington Post is Pravda on the Potomac
the absolute archetypal
megaphone for the political
establishment they're nothing but a
propaganda rag they would fit in great
in North Korea or China or Russia or
anywhere else
this is the headline in the Washington
Post
spread of Catholic Hospitals limits
reproductive care across the United
States
religious Doctrine restricts access to
abortion and birth control and limits
treatment options for miscarriages and
ectopic pregnancies
none of that is true that's just
a complete lie
think about the logic here
they're saying there are a lot of
Catholic Hospitals that's true the
Catholic church is the most
philanthropic organization in the
history of the world you might love the
Catholic Church you might hit the
Catholic church that's just an historic
fact the church has been around a long
time got a lot of resources and has done
a lot of charitable activities schools
hospitals all the rest of it so
especially the sister of hospitals
they're Catholic Hospitals all over the
place the Catholic Church builds
hospitals the church considers that part
of her mission in the world
how does building more hospitals
restrict
any kind of quote-unquote care
let's say I'm just making up numbers
here let's say you've got five lib
hospitals
and the lib hospitals trans the kids and
they kill the babies and they do all the
stuff that the libs like to do
and then the Catholic Church comes in
and it doesn't knock down the lib
hospitals even though it probably should
it doesn't go to the representatives and
say you got to get rid of all these lib
hospitals even though probably should
the Catholic church just builds more
hospitals
so you got five lib hospitals and then
you got let's say 15 Catholic Hospitals
and the Catholic Hospitals won't trans
the kids and won't kill the babies
in what world is that limiting access
even to the fake care or that the lizard
even even to translating the kids and
and killing the babies it's not doing
that at all
it's just offering
something different
but no good deed goes unpunished
especially in this liberal establishment
the libs can't take that if the Catholic
Church were going in and shutting down
liberal hospitals I would cheer that on
I would be there on the sidelines doing
jumping jacks waving pom-poms and
praying the rosary I would absolutely
love that that's not what's going on
that's not what the libs even have the
problem with the libs have the problem
with the Catholics just being Catholic
the lips have the problem with the
Catholics building hospitals to do
wonderful work to offer all kinds of
services if they won't also kill babies
and trans the kids that is how coercive
the left is that is how insistent and
totalitarian the left is that the left
is insisting on a total State not just
where they get to commit all their their
crimes against humanity and against poor
little kids not even just a state where
they have special privileges because the
state is liberal they are pushing for a
state where where Catholics don't get to
be Catholic
where Catholics don't get to have
hospitals where it would be better to
not have hospitals at all than to have
hospitals that don't trans the kids and
kill the babies
that is what we're talking about do you
think that that's
that would be the majority of you of the
people
do you think the majority of the people
think as the liberals do as the
Washington Post does that if a hospital
won't kill the babies and trans the kids
that it shouldn't be built or that it
should be shut down
of course not
the majority of people when you really
get down to the pro-life question
and you get into the nitty-gritty on on
in if if abortion is to be tolerated at
what point abortion should be tolerated
the country is overwhelmingly pro-life
in the vast majority of cases
that's not what the people want
is what the liberal ruling class wants
the the battle here is between the
democracy and the liberalism and the
liberalism right now is ruling and the
liberalism right now is winning even
though the people are being convinced
more and more and more that liberalism
is bad it doesn't matter the Liberals
still have so much of the power
speaking of church
there is some kind of fake church
somewhere
and actually there are a lot of fake
churches that have been doing this
you've seen a lot of clips of this I've
even heard stories of this anecdotally
from people I know who know of these
churches or who even attend these
churches that will invite drag queens in
to preach a kind of
transvestite pseudo-gospel specifically
two kids this is one that's just been
going viral over the last few days
if you have any questions from Miss
Pentecost
oh thank you
you like her eye shadow that's great
yeah yeah maybe she'll let you borrow it
when you're older when you're allowed to
wear makeup yeah
of course
yeah well one of the things I think is
great about Miss Pentecost is she
reminds us that we we follow a God who
calls us to not conform to things of
this world uh that we're supposed to be
transformed by the renewal of our minds
and that means that what I think today
may have to change tomorrow if I
continue to renew my mind and it's so
cool that we serve a God that calls us
to continue to grow and continue to to
change into something new
uh this is horrifying for many many
reasons but I will tell you
just as a sort of not a defense
but it just in all fairness to that drag
queen who calls himself
Miss penny cost so just this this
sacrilegious mockery of the Pentecost
when the the Holy Spirit descends and
makes so many thousands of disciples
I am much less offended by the guy who
puts on a dress and pretends to be a
woman
than I am by the other guy next to him
who dresses up and pretends to be a
priest
the man is obviously not a valid priest
I don't know which heretical systematic
sect of Christianity this is of I I read
somewhere it was some version of
methodism but uh whatever who knows some
obviously going completely insane
heretical
Blasphemous systematic sect of
Christianity
that's preaching an anti-gospel just
completely the opposite of Christianity
but worth pointing out too
Christ speaks very specifically in the
gospel about what that priest is doing
and what that transvestite is doing too
but but more so the priest and it's it's
a verse of the Gospel that is frequently
invoked in
in the transiting the kids debate or
especially in the abortion debate where
he says you know uh
the people who lead the littlest ones
astray
it would be better for them to have
millstones tied around their necks that
that is basically the effect of what
will happen if you lead the little ones
astray
who who offends the least of of these
people and if the verse is often
misinterpreted to mean people who just
you know go out and smack a kid or abuse
a child or you know kill a baby in the
womb or something like that but it it's
the verse is not really speaking about
you know beating a child the verse is
speaking about the sin of Scandal
leading someone astray causing someone
to stumble that's what the priest is
doing
and it's a it's an absolutely horrifying
scene obviously and no one should attend
that ridiculous church and the priest
should get another job and beg
forgiveness from God
but it shows you what leftism does it it
ties in forgetting the religious
question for putting it aside for a
second it shows you what leftism does
leftism goes into every Institution
and cuts it open like the opening scene
of The Empire Strikes Back and pulls out
the guts of that thing and then crawls
inside and starts to animate it like
night night of the living dead that's
what it does
and it does it with Priestly a tie or it
does it with the churches it does with
the universities it does it with our
systems of government and it creates a
kind of a show a deceit
a sock puppet theater
of our public institutions of our
politics and I when I say politics I
don't just mean Schoolhouse Rock You
Know Capitol Hill and everything I'm
talking about all of the Power centers
that we have the the businesses the the
universities the classrooms all of it it
goes in and it makes a kind of show of
everything
and it often pretends that there's even
political opposition but there's not
there is just ultimately the kind of
uniparty and it's leading people to be
deeply distrustful of the established
institutions this is what is leading
Tulsi gabbard to to fall away from the
Democrat Party it's what's leading a lot
of trump supporters to say look I like
Trump I want to make America great again
I'm conservative I'm right-wing but I'm
not some establishment Republican I
disagree with the Republican
establishment on many if not most issues
okay I guess I'm just something
different I'm just a crazy guy
who doesn't want to kill the babies
doesn't want to trans the kids wants to
waive the American flag wants to have
actual borders doesn't want to engage in
adventurism overseas and lead to nuclear
Armageddon I call me crazy that's just
what I
that's just me
and a lot of people are there
I bet a plurality of the people are
pretty much somewhere right around there
if not an outright majority of the
people
and increasingly as as the liberal
establishment doubles down right
whenever people question the liberal
establishment's power what do they do
they start putting up big fences and
barricades and barbed wire in Washington
D.C what does the liberal establishment
do they start censoring you they kick
you off social media they de-platform
you they take your money out of PayPal
they freeze your accounts they arrest
you they investigate you in some cases I
mean they're really getting much more
aggressive they call parents domestic
terrorists for questioning what their
kids are learning in schools they call
half the country semi-fascists they're
really really tightening their grip
right now in power and so you're going
to see this debate as we move into 20
the end of 2022 2023 2024 the battle is
not going to be Republican versus
Democrat necessarily even really left
versus right exactly
you're going to see a battle in this
cracking up of what has been understood
to be the American system in recent
years which is liberal democracy it's
going to be that crack up there and it's
going to be a debattle but between the
liberalism and the Democracy pick a side
the rest of the show is continuing now
in the members block it is work
Wednesday and so my producer Ben Davies
has teed up a new challenge for me
it is from the channel love don't judge
and the challenge is to see how long I
can just totally simply merely love
without any kind of judgments whatsoever
creeping into my head I'm not sure how
long I'm going to make it if you are not
a member click the link in the
description and join us we will see you
on the member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]